[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages in the next half hour or
so then
we will see what's making the headlines
with sonia soda chief leader writer at
the observer
and anita boateng former conservative
special adviser great to see you both
as ever let's check out the front pages
rotten to the core that is the daily
mail's verdict on the
metropolitan police which was found to
be institutionally corrupt
over its handling of private
investigator daniel morgan
the metro says all over 18s should be
able to grab their jab
by the end of this week delhi telegraph
leads with the headline no green light
to start vaccinating children
while the guardian says covet vaccines
are to be made
mandatory for care home staff the daily
express
celebrates the uk australia trade deal
saying
it's a fantastic brexit boost the
yorkshire post
also leads on the uk's post-brexit trade
deal with australia
and how it could affect the welfare of
animals in the uk
and this is how the deal is being
reported down under the australian
pictures prime minister scott morrison
with the queen
saying he sealed a historic pact with
the uk
the eye investigates mental health
treatment finding that it has been
withheld from people
who frequently turn to the emergency
services for help
fabrice muamba who suffered a cardiac
arrest during a football game like
denmark's christian eriksen
has called for more defibrillators in
public places according to the mirror
financial times focusing on chancellor
rishi sunak
and his 4 billion pound bill from next
year if he's to stick to the tory's
triple
lock pension pledge jennifer saunders he
wrote and starred in absolutely fabulous
has told the son she doesn't think she
would get away with making the sitcom
today criticizing
what she calls the small-mindedness of
today's so-called woke era
and the star says yuri gellar has vowed
to help scotland beat england
in the euros on friday using psychic
energy is it the kilt
i don't know uh we'll find out later
maybe
so sonya soda chief leader at the
observer anita boten former conservative
special adviser
are here welcome and great to see both
of you let's kick off shall we with the
uh daily mail um anita this is obviously
a historic
case um which has legacy issues right
through to today
absolutely and this really goes to the
heart of the issue of trust
um you know the contract between the
public and the police
is one that requires a great deal of
trust and it's pretty shocking and
pretty remarkable
that the metropolitan police had to
produce a report such as this
which resulted in which exposed levels
upon levels
of institutional failings and i you know
my heart really does go out to the
family
absolutely and our home editor brought
it in all three massive volumes of it
took years and years partly because the
daily mail as elsewhere as we heard
today
is accused the commissioner rather is
accused of of blocking evidence
um what what did you make of the
findings today sonia
well i think it's so damning for the met
and i think at first glance people might
look at this and think
you know it's a terrible murder that
happened in 1987.
that's really bad and what it reveals
about the met is really bad but what
relevance does it have today but of
course
it has taken so long for um
this man's family to get to the trees
and it's only through their sort of
persistent
not going away demanding an inquiry that
this has happened
and what it does find is that you know
even into the present day there have
been
multiple reviews into this death which
um
you know which have found failings in
the met police but even today and even
in the last kind of two
three years uh during which uh this
panel has been meeting
they find that that crescendo dick and
the met have not
opened themselves up to scrutiny and
that's really really problematic it's
very damning for the met
because there's this case of course of
an institutionalized corruption
is a very very strong uh uh
sort of uh way to describe what's been
going on at the map but you put it with
other reasons that the that people
living in london have not
to trust the police so the met police so
the fact that
stop and search rates are still so much
higher for young black men than other
members of the population
the policing of the sarah everard vigil
and and caressa de dix
a sort of defensiveness in the wake of
that and then of course you've got the
whole spy cop
scandal in which police officers um you
know were sort of
lying to women having affairs with them
in some cases even having children with
women
based on completely fake relationship as
part of sort of political spying
operations
so i think it's incredibly damning for
the met and it is the latest
thing to show that there are real
institutional problems and i think
that's why it's quite a serious thing to
call for the
the met commissioners to stand down but
it's not the first time that it's
happened to chris as a dick in the last
two or three years
and i think it's reflective of the fact
that there's just so much
mounting evidence actually that there is
institutionalize a culture of
institutionalized
uh corruption and and cover-up in the in
the met police and that's why people
have been calling for her to go
but but it hasn't anita just final
thought on this become a default thing
to ask for the person as the top to go
rather than read
all the hundreds of pages of the report
is it appropriate in this case do you
think or do we need to look a bit more
deeply
well i think you make the key point
which is that it's very easy to think
that the um the problem will be sold
with the person at the top
changes it feels to me as though there
are some cultural
issues you know sonya's talked about
some of them and um that
lie underneath a lot of these issues and
it seems as though
the light of transparency is something
that the met police seems to resist at
important moments and as andrew has said
like the police have gone through a very
difficult year
there have been some real challenges
around policing of
whether it's a pandemic whether it's
server errors murder
or whether it's the issues around um the
relationship between bame communities
and the police and what we need is more
openness and less resistance now i'm not
sure
that all of that can be solved by
changing the head
and it feels as though we reach for that
solution um
as a way to kind of solve ourselves of
responsibility and the hard work i think
it's going to take
to build that trust back between the
police and the public
we'll move on if you don't mind raft of
covert stories perhaps not surprisingly
after
yesterday's delay scotland today as well
putting
uh going to level zero to july the 19th
uh similar to england um first of all to
the metro
this race of the vaccine despite reports
again that the fisa supply
um shortage forces jab's rollout to slow
down the age ranges
are being rattled through quite quickly
now aren't they sonya
yeah see this is sort of the the
positive side i suppose of of vaccines
which is that
the government is shortly going to uh
open up booking to all adults over 18
which is a really really good thing
and so the metro's got that positive
spin but i think we're just about to
come on to
a story from the telegraph and i think
it's really interesting putting these
two stories together
because obviously the fact that all
adults are going to be able to get their
book for their job soon and the
government uh thinks that all adults
will have had their first job by july
the 19th is
is the positive spin that the government
uh wants us to kind of
know about but there are real concerns
about vaccine supply and i think what
the telegraph story does is first of all
it highlights concerns around the supply
of the pfizer vaccine which of course is
really important because under 40
if you're under 40 you know the
recommendation is for you to get pfizer
or moderna preferably
so that's a bit tricky um but it also
makes clear that vaccination rates have
actually
slowed quite significantly we're now
behind some of the leading countries on
the continent in terms of rate at which
we're vaccinating
in terms of number of jobs per week now
we're still doing well
so this is not to be churnish about it
but the story makes the point
that if we were vaccinating at the rate
that we had been back in march
and let's face it it's not because of a
a lack of people coming forward for
these vaccinations there's a lot of
public enthusiasm for it
um but if if we were vaccinating at the
same rate that we were in march
we would have actually um finished
people would have got their first jabs
uh probably a full month before july the
19th
so i do think it is important to um
at the same time as we're all very
relieved about the vaccination i think
there are serious questions for
journalists to ask here
about supply about why rates of
vaccination have slowed down
just when it's so critical in terms of
opening up and that's probably got
something to do with the delay
yes the the the telegraph suggesting
that just 1.2 million
first doses were dispensed in the last
week compared to more than 3 million a
week
earlier in the program with the uk now
lagging behind germany italy and france
and certainly one metric the world in
data suggested we now have
the highest covert figures in europe so
it's all gone wrong in that sense hasn't
it certainly with the delta variant
um some suggesting that actually younger
people should be offered
the astrazeneca vaccine anita and make
their own decision about
their own how they feel about that risk
benefit and that would certainly speed
it up
the other story we saw there on the
daily telegraph was this no green light
to start vaccinating children the
telegraph suggesting
that experts on the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization
are expected to make a recommendation
against the vaccination of
under 18s in the immediate future
the committee is understood to be
preparing for an interim statement
for release as soon as the end of the
week following a meeting
today this is a really interesting issue
isn't it how far
down under the age of 18 you go what's
your feeling anita
um my sense is that it seems as though
we do have to cover off some of these
secondary school children because
um during the pandemic we did see
evidence that they were part of that
chain of transmission that did mean that
numbers um remained relatively high
community so i definitely think it's
something that
it's one of those issues very much where
we have to be data-led and so i'd be
very interested to see
how that debate um continues and we are
learning things about the vaccine
every minute of every day thanks to the
brilliant scientists that we have but
i guess my instinct is that it seems
like secondary schools were one of the
areas where we did see
increased transmission and just to pick
up on sonia's point
about the issue of the number of people
that are now able to come forward and
get vaccinated i think it's very clear
to me and from having seen what happened
in israel and other countries that as
you increase the volumes of vaccination
as it goes through the country
it becomes a little harder and in terms
of you having to vaccinate and find new
people
it's not simply the case that you have a
hundred vaccines and two million people
that want to take them
and also that we are obviously dealing
with having to get out second doses and
those have to be timed
and then of course we've got the third
factor which is that some people
are requiring a little more support and
encouragement to get
them to take the vaccine i'm absolutely
delighted that the figures
of vaccine hesitancy so-called vaccine
hesitancy
amongst vme communities seems to be
reaching the same as as
white people in the country and i think
that's a really good sign um i think
that it seems to me that the vaccine
rollout
is progressing at pace and we're
possibly at a harder stage
where we have to reach people um that
are not just sort of
there's not lots of people left to be
back i'm so sorry we don't have time
we could talk about that all night or i
know i could um we will talk about that
more at 11. i know you're staying with
us plenty more in the next part of this
program though
why is the nhs having to turn away
mental health patients
talking about that in just a moment
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now our sony soda
chief leader writer at the observer and
anita boten
former conservative special adviser
welcome back to both of you
um to the yorkshire post we go now
australia pact will erode uk animals
welfare one issue of many to discuss
after this
first trade deal started from scratch
sonia that's right and i think the
reason why farmers are so worried is
that australia has
lower regulatory standards for food for
things like dairy products for lamb
and beef than we do here in the uk so
what they're concerned about
is that um once the tariff free
uh sort of race period expires
in this trade deal you're gonna get um
cheaper australia and new zealand meat
and dairy products
come into the uk market and that it's
gonna be very very difficult
for british farmers where we have higher
welfare standards to compete i think
this
is a real problem and i think it is one
of the flaws
in sort of plan for brexit it makes it
i'm going to cut it
i don't mean to interrupt you we just
have one minute left anita go for it
it just feels as though the people that
supported remain can't have it both ways
like
either the fact that the australian
trade was never going to make up for eu
trade or it's going to be the absolute
end of
animal welfare standards and um you know
good price
meet until the end of time it feels to
me as though
this has been phased in over 15 years
there is a lot of focus from australian
farmers on the asian market where meat
is much much higher
and ultimately the uk is going to
continue to have enormously high trading
standards
and even the yorkshire post piece kind
of acknowledges there might be
some risk around you know from the nfu
saying what about
animal welfare not that there's anything
tangible in this deal that will have a
negative impact
on animal welfare anita sonia
great stuff we will see for more on that
and all the things we didn't yet discuss
of which there's a long list is there
not see for more at 11 thank you both
very much indeed